Hello Freak bitches.
I want queefs.
I don't break for queets,
you know,
like you're fucking going and you hear
that and they sort of want to stop
fucking.
That's like I'm driving on the highway
and someone goes,
Hey,
okay,
let me ask you this.
Did he push you when they're on their
period?
Uh,
I used to,
but as I got older,
no,
don't give a fuck.
I used to fuck chicks with Shane a lot.
And how dare you.
We would accidentally touch dicks
sometimes.
Like one time I was just like,
that operation game.
I thought I was fucking a girl in her
ass and it went into her current and
actually went into his condom inside.
I'm looking down at her.
How looses his condom?
What is it?
A fucking trash bag.
I was harder.
They make sense,
at least resistance.
So I'm looking down at Man,
I swear to God on got inside his condom.
Yep.
So using the condom ever believes me
about this container so that you guys
could rub dicks together.
But that wasn't the plan,
but I was,
I was like,
I'm fucking bitches ass.
And I looked down and I see an asshole
and I'm like,
how many apples does this woman assuming
I'm in,
at least one of them.
And then I reached down and I feel a
condom.
How drunk were you guys?
Not Drunk at all.
Well,
how did you not know where you're
putting your Dick?
Don't you look?
What are you looking at on the ass?
You're pushing and pushing and pushing
and then you sort of feel that it
slipped.
So you'd go,
oh,
that must have gone into a hole.
The one that was pushing this girl doing
the whole time.
Calling with
Donald Sutherland.
Yeah.
Invasion of the body snatchers.
Well,
she's got to Dixon and vaginas.
She's fucking hoster.
Listen,
she was from Malta.
I hate to wrap this up on a,
on a high note like that.
But we're out of time at the end of the
story.
So anyway,
I've,
I've reached down,
I go,
I didn't have a condom on and I have a
condom on and then I pull out and I
busted out on her butt and uh,
people go,
but you touched a dick.
But when you're doing that kind of
stuff,
it's like two mobsters digging a hole
for a body and their shovels clink.
Like you don't fucking know
where you're at work.
Right?
I understand.
I see.
I want them to get you wrap that up.
Nice.
Tight.
Do you know I had a revelation the other
day when it came to movies.
Uh,
I went to see the Martian.
It was pretty good.
Interesting.
But the problem is,
the problem with that movie is,
you know,
he's gonna live,
he's gonna make it so it's like someone
gave you a spoiler alert before you even
got to the movie.
It's like,
oh,
is he going to die on Mars?
Am I paying money to watch two hours of
him and he's going to die on Mars.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Everybody knows he's not going to die on
Mars.
But the revelation was there's,
there's too many movies.
And like even really awesome movies like
Sicario is supposed to be pretty bad ass
because that's the new Benicio Del Toro
movie.
It's supposed to be pretty bad ass,
but we couldn't get a ticket to that
one.
I'm in time.
Uh,
we,
we were sold out so we went with the
Martian.
Um,
but the point is these movies never stop
every week.
There's new ones and they don't go away.
Like the old ones.
Don't stop being around like you can go
watch them too.
It's like there's too many of them.
Like I was thinking about all the
different movies just on itunes and
Netflix and I was scrolling through them
and I started thinking like,
this is a,
this is a never ending equation.
Like it just keeps getting tacked onto
it.
We live in the epicenter of where it's
created.
It's all around here and it's,
it's very strange because the body of
work just never stops.
Like he used to be when I was a kid.
When a good movie came out,
you would go to see that fucking movie,
like Star Wars.
I saw star wars 13 times and I was
nothing compared to the real geeks.
Like there's,
there was like,
it was a big deal back then to see how
many times you could see a movie,
like you couldn't run a movie long
enough to see for someone to see it 13
times now because there's new ones,
there's new ones come in,
we've got to get this fucking piece of
shit out of the theater.
You would never have a movie like star
wars.
It played over and over and over and
over and over and over again.
And if star wars came out today,
people would shit right in it's mouth.
It's,
it's weird.
That is to me in my childhood,
one of the greatest movies of all time
when I was a kid and that movie came
out.
I remember when Obi wan Kenobi was
talking to Luke Skywalker and uh,
they were in the sand.
I was like,
this is the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life.
This is amazing.
This guy's in space and he's gonna Obi
wan Kenobi is going to teach them how to
be a jet.
I,
oh,
this is the greatest movie ever.
I remember.
It couldn't have been more perfect.
I remember seeing that movie and
thinking,
this movie is fucking perfect.
Now you go watch and you're like,
oh my God,
it's such a clunky Turd.
It's clunky.
The special effects look like shit.
Why has darth vader evil?
Does he,
does he just not even a reason why he's
evil?
He's just evil.
What does he get when he takes over the
world is even get pussy is even going to
get any pussy in space.
He know he's just building some giant
star that can blow up planets.
Really?
This is so dumb.
Like it's so dumb.
Oh,
uses the dark side.
Oh No.
If the dog.
So it's so fucking dumb.
Um,
and it's puppets.
It's like kermit the frog and Skywalker.
But in its day,
like if you judge it in the context of
its day,
it's one of the all time classic films.
It's just,
there's so many more now and they're
better.
Let's say you are a fighter,
for example,
you got to have opponent,
but this time the opponent is yourself
and uh,
and you know it from the inside and you
feel it from the inside and it makes you
happy,
it makes you strong and makes you
healthy.
And this is what we have lost from the
nature and now it's back.
So,
so in a sense,
what you've done is you tapped into
something extremely primal by dealing
with one of the most primal elements at
all of all,
which is cold.
Yes.
So the cold in the vice documentary,
I thought that was really fascinating.
You said cold is your God.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
If I had a teacher,
I've never had a teacher that's,
that's amazing.
I Know Guru or mentor or Sifu or
anything like that.
The cold.
That's my teacher.
That's my God.
I've been dodging the colts and tells a
little kid.
It's amazing.
You just felt compelled to jump into
that.
Yes,
absolutely.
And what was,
when you're saying this to people when
you're 31 years old and you're telling
people I can control my immune system,
that they must have been like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Look at this guy's jumping into the
freezing water and he says he can
control his immune system.
How did you convince people to the point
that you got actual scientist to measure
your blood?
Do legitimate scientific studies on you?
Like what was it your accomplishments
like you went for people that don't know
you,
you did a bunch of really unbelievable
tasks.
You climbed everest in your shorts.
Um,
did you have shoes on when you climbed
everest?
Yes,
I had to with spikes.
Spikes climbing,
right?
No,
no.
Showed on.
I think I go and buy clothes.
It's insane because it's like you are
not challenging nature.
You can go up with with their car as
well.
And then you'll go up everest.
Anything artificial you use in nature
doesn't make you having the right
connection with nature.
And what I wanted to challenge in all
the challenges I did,
like marathons beyond the polar circle
in midwinter short,
but also in the heat of the desert
without drinking or hanging by one
finger,
one slash Columbia,
or like a mile up in the air in winter
time.
You hung up by one finger a mile up in
the air.
Yes.
Where was this alternate holidays
between two hot air balloons and then
climbing between them.
And then there was a,
you know,
a thing,
a device I could looked it on with one
finger.
Yes.
How long did you hang there for?
A 25 seconds.
Five seconds.
And with one finger.
And in wintertime,
winter time,
you know,
you lose control when the blood becomes
colder into hands,
you lose control.
So that was the challenge.
It's mind over matter.
And I wanted to show that in all the
challenges,
the adaptive power of ours is enormous,
but as we are not stimulating or using
that anymore,
you get a neglected body and become sick
or half in its potency.
And so very logic.
So the powers that our body has,
the untapped power that we probably had
for millennia,
dealing with the cold,
dealing with the heat,
dealing with adversity,
dealing with struggle,
all those powers are not being tapped
into.
So because of that,
the body just atrophies and we don't.
It doesn't know what to do with
yourself.
Exactly.